[Music]  whenever you say spider-man  you always mean the other one  you're spiderman i'm fresher than fresh  i step out the steps and we're all  running for the flights pete tell me i  was next i'm coming for next it really  isn't no question  only super hills intersection only big  bang  [Music]  necklace  [Music]  you can't stop me  [Music]  i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready  girl i'm the one gotta tell them young  with the vision and they couldn't see it  man just like the picture developed  i got it  [Music]  i'm ready to go  [Music]  to take  [Applause]  [Music]  shoot each other all right  [Music]  i'm ready  [Music]  [Applause]  i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready  [Music]  man i still can't get over that suit  it's so cool  got to be me yeah you do  playstation